bienvenidos a cultura versión casa por
la pandemia en la cinta yoyo rabbit el
protagonista se gana esta puedo tras
negarse a matar un conejo es la primera
decisión que lo diferencia de la
crueldad nace y no hay anécdota que
resuma mejor el corto save ralphs que
además tienen por voz central al
director taika waititi porque ser más yo
yos frente al maltrato animal en pruebas
cosméticas es lo que nos pide el grupo
human society international y lo hace la
white y con ironía entrevista a rne que
si bien sufre dolores y querrían llorar
dice que son gajes del oficio de conejo
probador el feliz de servir a nuestros
desodorantes aunque haya métodos que lo
eviten
no
esto es que tuve
sabemos que esto es horrible pero
entonces debemos dejar de comprar marcas
que usan animales cómo saber cuál es el
proceso no se prohíbe sobre los océanos
son preguntas que empezó a hacerse al y
travis y cineasta fiel yo yo recogedor
de plástico en playas y consumidor de
atún eco hasta que filmar se inspira así
queriendo dar un paso más le cambió esta
visión cambiando a su vez la nuestra
existen infinitos documentales sobre
ecosistemas polución o pesca y este
tiene algunas cositas por revisar pero
no fuerte es que atraviesa todos los
males
la praxis ilegal en la recogida
accesoria cómo afectan las aves marinas
y a la cadena alimentaria para
evidenciar la hipocresía que rodea el
hecho de que estamos destruyendo el 85
por ciento del oxígeno que respiramos es
lo que generan los océanos y en su
trasfondo hay organizaciones sostenibles
que no lo son empresas que actúan como
mafias encubiertas falso marketing
esclavitud observadores asesinados y
horribles piscifactorías
son muertos
claro debemos actuar el engaño es
culparnos por el plástico cuando la
pesca comercial extermina océanos con el
46% de la basura como expone se inspira
así que además de explicar el porqué de
reducir o borrar el consumo de peces
ahonda muy bien en el sufrimiento animal
algo que cunda del realizador ruso
victor kossakovsky combina con belleza
fílmica y algunas averías lo suyo es un
poema que va de la cerda aguda a
gallinas y vacas a una paz que se oye
maltratada por los humanos si bien no se
juzga las granjas ni es un modelo de
consumo y a la vez sí pero como metáfora
de nuestra humanidad y del dolor final
en otros temas el avance del cómic 19
también acelera la agonía artística en
un balance del año vivido y con datos de
104 mil museos de 87 países la unesco
alerta que muchos no sólo no verán más
públicos sino que tendrán en peligro su
patrimonio saben del domo de cinerama
que aparece en el filme huanza con el
timing hollywood su extinción ya es una
realidad con el cierre de la cadena de
cine es pacific y and clyde mítica en
california adiós al icono de 1963
mientras que en bogotá la esperanza
resurge con la inauguración de un teatro
de acertado nombre el ensueño su
escenario es un revés al virus pero
sobre todo una voluntad de llevar música
dramaturgia y circo a un sur capitalino
pobre inaccesible y sin cultura local
john lennon y yoko ono han alegrado las
semanas sentados en un sofá con miradas
cómplices y errando letra en un vídeo
que es técnicamente la primera actuación
del tema give peace a change de 69 mick
jagger ha ofrecido su propia sorpresa
con un tema rock con dave grohl y sin el
resto de los rolling stones que hace
referencia al hastío zone de la
cancelación de conciertos pero antes de
estos contemporáneos hubo unas divas que
agrandaron las artes árabes al
contribuir con sus vidas y talentos a
cambios profundos del cairo a beirut del
magreb a parís impulsaron desde los años
20 una nueva imagen de mujer y una
renovación política de sentido
independiente anti colonización y
feminista que en el caso de la bailarina
egipcia talla cairo que la llevó a la
cárcel por simpatías comunistas mujeres
emancipadas en un mundo patriarcal así
podría resumirse el itinerario divas de
un call zoom adalid a con el que rinde
tributo el instituto del mundo árabe de
parís desde los años veinte estas
pioneras protagonizaron musicales en
egipto siendo asimismo actrices y
productoras son nombres poco conocidos
pero con roles primordiales
fueron ellas quienes impulsaron el
movimiento en la región todas son
personalidades excepcionales que se
emanciparon de la dominación masculina
mujeres visionarias que abrieron camino
a las grandes divas árabes de después y
que están en una segunda parte de la
exposición bajo la luz de los focos de
antaño las legendarias un call zoom
cyrus guarda y haz mahan estrellas cuya
intimidad se conserva hoy en pasaportes
joyas y suntuosos vestidos con su
canción fue la cantante más grande del
mundo árabe desde los años 30 hasta
incluso hoy cyrus es un monumento de la
canción libanesa o guarda cuenta una
historia algo distinta a la de una
cantante del exilio nacida en francia
con carrera en egipto y us mahan
princesa rusa de origen sirio-libanés
que jugó un rol vital en la música de
en parís o más allá en las redes del
instituto hay espacio para descubrir las
mujeres que eran feministas como la
bailarina talla carioca y la historia
única de asma jan que además de voz e
actriz fue espía estos vídeos nos
permiten compartirlo hacer vivir la
exposición aquí el protagonismo es para
ellas mujeres vanguardistas cuya
prestancia y libertad sirvió de
inspiración a las generaciones venideras
con su esencia y su poderío
revolucionario despedimos esta crónica
más cultura en el siguiente enlace y ha
sido un placer como siempre piense mucho
[Música]